كان من سرق ارشيف الوكاله الوطنيه للاعلام
اراد سرقه ذاكره لبنان فالارشيف الذي
فقدته الوكاله غني بما يناهز مليوني ومئتي
الف صوره صوره وذكريات وصور تؤرخ لحقبه
لبنان وشخصيته ومناسبات ترجع لعام 1961 في
حادثه وصفتها وزاره الاعلام بجريمه بحجم
الوطن لكن وزير الاعلام في حكومه تصريف
الاعمال زياد مكاري حاولت تهدئه قائلا ان
الجزء المسروق لا تزال قاعده معلوماته
محفوظه في الوزاره ولم تفقد وهذا ما تبين
بعد التاكد من الموجودات الاغراب في
القضيه التي فاجات واحزنت اللبنانيين ان
السرقه وقعت في منطقه محصنه امنيه
فالوكاله تقع في مقر وزاره الاعلام في
بيروت الملاصقه لوزاره الداخليه والبنك
المركزي
وهنا يطرح السؤال مع سرق الارشيف نسال
ايضا ماذا ضاع من ذاكره لبنان
[موسيقى]
من البترون في الشمال لبنان تنضم الينا
المديره السابقه للوكاله الوطنيه للاعلام
لور سليمان اهلا بك سيده معنا في صباح
العربيه يعني حادثه غريبه ان يسرق لصوص
ارشيف الوكاله الوطنيه للاعلام هل لكم او
لديكم اي تفاصيل جديده حول هذه الحادثه
صباح الخير بدايه
واسمحي لي اهنيكم بعيد العربيه العشرين
واهنيك بعيد ميلادك
اهني كل امهات لبنان بهذا الشهر وامهات
العالم العربي كمان
اللي صار بالسرقه الارشيف بالوكاله
الوطنيه هو ليس اهانه بقدر ما هو جريمه
لانه ما سرق هو
ذاكره لبنان
التي
بدات على سنوات منذ سنه
من تاريخ تاسيس الوكاله يعني من عهد
الرئيس فؤاد شهاب
ارشيف الوكاله قيم جدا مثل ما ذكرتي
مليونين و 200 الف صوره نيجاتيف تم تقييم
سنه 2010 تقريبا
عندما بدانا العمل جديا بهذا الارشيف
طيب استاذه نور انها جريمه لا توصف ويجب
قره الفاعلين وكلمه اشد العقوبات بهم
ومحاسبه
والمهملين بهذا الموضوع عندما نتحدث عن
جريمه وصفت بان جريمه بحجم وطن ماذا كان
يريد السارق من هذه السرقه
يبدو اننا هل تسمعيني طيب يبدو انه فقدنا
الاتصال مع استاذه لنعود مره اخرى الى
البترون في شمال لبنان والى المديره
السابقه للوكاله الوطنيه للاعلام لور
سليمان لور اهلا بك معنا مجددا اليوم اذا
نتحدث لوجستيا يعني مثل هكذا ارشيف وانتم
في السابق استلمتموه ونفضتوه يعني
بالعاميه يعني وطورتوه اكثر فاكثر الا
يفترض بان يكون محفوظا نظرا لاهميته كما
ذكرتي
نحن ان ما بدانا العمل
بدانا بارشادته
بدايه على سيرفر ولكن طلبت منهم انا ان
ينقلوه على
لنقله فيما بعد ولكن
كنا في انتظار ان
يكتمل العدد على المطلوب على الاكسترنر
لنقله لحفظه في مصرف لبنان ولكن للاسف
تم اقالتي في 22 تشرين الاول 2019 ولم
اكمل ما بدات به من عمل لذلك لا اعلم
ان الجزء المسروق تحديدا قاعده معلوماته
محفوظه في الوزاره الى اي مدى هذا مطمئن
صحيح
النيجاتيف مثل ما قال معالي الوزير انه
بعده موجود
ولكن جهود
زملاء لالنا من العام 2011 بدايه الحفظ
هذه المعلومات
2023 راحت سدى يعني
بالعمل اللي حصل هو 25% تقريبا من الكميه
الموجوده
هذه هذا العمل كله راح سوده في خلال هذه
الفتره
من خلال هذه الجريمه التي ماذا كان يريد
السارق من هكذا سرقه بالاساس ماذا كان
يريد السارق من هذه السرقه بالاساس على
ماذا كان يريد ان يحصل والى اين سيصل
من الممكن انه كان ينوي
سرقه ذاكره لبنان ربما اعتقد ان كل
المعلومات هي موجوده في هذه في هذا
السيرفر ولم يعلم من الممكن انه لم يعلم
ان في في الكلاسيك الموجوده على الرفوف
هناك صور النجاتيف او لو لم يكن معه الوقت
الكافي لنقل كل شيء لا اعلم ما هي نيته في
الحقيقه او للتخريب ممكن
السيده لور وزير الاعلام في حكومه تصريف
الاعمال يقول بان هذه السرقه ماديه
ومعنويه ماديه كيف ومعنويه لماذا
اولا ماديه لان الاجهزه التي سرقت
والمحتوى
على هذه الاجهزه
كبير جدا وقيم لانه ذاكره لبنان وتاريخ
لبنان في هذه الصور اما
معنويه ايضا
هذه المواد لها قيمه وطنيه كبرى وخصوصا ان
هذه الصور لا يمتلكها ايا كان هي ارشيف
دالاتي ونهره منذ العام 61 كما قلنا
يعني هي في اساسها هنا في الوكاله الوطنيه
للاعلام
بشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك معنا لور
سليمان المديره السابقه للوكاله الوطنيه
للاعلام شكرا لك